[Music]
i don't know about you guys but i
really miss traveling so when i found
out i don't because i've been traveling
still
i know you still travel don't brag about
that joe
just kidding just kidding just kidding
but you have been traveling what are you
kidding about
i know but i just interrupted tiff and i
said 2020 is not the year of
interrupting anyone
thank you i appreciate that no well yeah
so i found this website
called window swap that i absolutely
fell in love with
windows swap yes it's freaking i love it
because it's so pure and simplistic and
so like
raw and so like like uh it's so
beautiful you're simplistic and raw
dude what are we talking about windows
what is it what's the buzz
yes we're talking about windows it's
passionate it's loving it's
it's beautiful it's kind of rapey it's
windows windows
windows 96
all right so this couple they had been
feeling
like just cabin fever just always being
at home
and they got sick and tired of staring
at the same view
out of their window so they came up with
this website called window swap
where people can submit videos of their
windows and so i mean i have a clip
here's how you get stalkers
well you just you maybe you just don't
show what you look like remember that
one guy
that we did an article where he found
out where that girl lived by the
reflection in her eyes
well that was like she was he was a
hardcore like fan and obsessive
but this one don't want to share my
window those people exist this is what
she's you share your window all the time
don't tell anyone you're like today is
[Laughter]
you have a big window and i like it
don't even talk about it all right [ __ ]
it
moving on moving on alright so i have a
video here
to show what window swap is all about
that's a big ass window dude
that's a door is that cheating it's kind
of cheating isn't it
yeah that's not a window that's a
sliding door plus yeah
what is a window and 2020 on windows
whatever it wants to be
yeah yeah so here you can see the
person's name oh it's got a door
and [ __ ] sliding glass the whole
thing is window
and i'm here the whole thing's door
[Applause]
oh look at the very left it's like it's
like a glass door legit door
who's never seen a sliding glass door
before
okay joe try try not to get amazed with
the rest of these windows okay
just try to it's a big window you're
right that's a pretty view though so
here you can see the locations this is
in scotland
is that the one that's raw or is that
the one that's passionate
wait a minute they paint it oh i love
that
that is insane that's beautiful it's a
boomerang dude that's the [ __ ] shire
bro
you could hear the audio too yeah like
it really just transports you to this
person's home that's this one's
chaotic no i don't like it yeah this one
they're constructing next window
trash windows yeah you can click you can
click this button and this is my
favorite one actually from okinawa
oh that's okinawa
i stayed on that window for like an hour
[ __ ]
that one's boring that one go to work
window judging
that's any suburb surfing that's not
even a window but we're judging yeah
[ __ ] your window this guy sucks i kind
of like it
i like the colors is that san francisco
it looks so good
it is we're here you guys i miss san
francisco
oh i like that that's pretty nice it's
very clean that's west hollywood
singapore oh [ __ ] yeah so
you singapore i actually found this very
like
meditating too it just feels really like
just peaceful does your window suck
i like my window a lot it has a really
nice view but it just felt really nice
to be
like transported also with like your
headphones you could hear
everything like the ambiance and i
personally really loved it
um like a hot or not for windows like i
don't like your window yeah you're just
swiping
hey call me back when the crane's gone
okay yeah next
or different time of days that'd be so
cool can you submit a window of someone
else's window
looking inside their house can you
submit a revenge window
what does that mean i don't know like
revenge it sounds like we're trading
picks like
nude pics like revenge points like a
stocky i was that like a stocky point of
view oh oh i see
someone like changed from yeah
and it's like a webcam that goes in the
house so the window it's blacked out
like two circles like this
you've seen those tv binocular ones yeah
have you seen those tv windows where
people will
will put up a tv and then they have it
like screensaver just some something
where it looks like a window it looks
sick oh you know what's pretty calming
walkthroughs city walkthroughs they have
like three
four hours just straight up wow yeah
it's like on a drone or whatever it is
and then um there's like ones for tokyo
or kyoto and then
they're they're just going i'm seeing
island i saw that one
very relaxing very relaxing where do you
find those
just on youtube my favorite one is las
vegas
and kyoto japan i did that virtually
before
like before i discovered people doing
that because i did hear about people
actually walking through cities
um but i would actually go on the the
apple
maps before they change the way that
their maps are actually i think they
still have it but in certain cities you
could see like a 3d version of it and so
it'll actually like give you like a tour
of the city like over like aerial view
but then i'll also get in like google
google map earth google earth and then
actually like walk through the the
street
is it an even pace because when i'm
looking at the street it's like
can you get slam into the wall shouldn't
you slam into a house is it
even pacer you could actually see or you
have to like teleport yeah
uh the 3d aerial it's like like like
you're flying through the city so it's
really smart
it's oh yeah i want to try that because
the google earth version one where
you're actually walking through the
street is like that yeah you kind of get
carsick even though you're not in a car
yeah if vr got good enough i'm chill
with just like
chilling on a vr beach like if it goes
like water way too much i know but like
if i can't see the water right now like
i see it like once or twice a year these
days
you can just get two bowls fill it up
with sandwiches
my feet in like some sand with water go
to sandbox
yeah and then lay there and then get a
fan oh yeah wait who said that
someone said well that's why if i see it
being different and then my feet are
just feeling the same sand
but it looks different you could make
that work i could see you making that
one
steve just holds kelp next to your nose
and then you just have like someone else
going ah
yeah i like it has to have the like
people's doing this there's no sound
effects
that are involved i like how bart thinks
that my only skill is that i hold kelp
somebody else would have to make a car
sound everything here you're gonna do a
classic a sick car sound actually
go go
that wouldn't be beach though that's
more like midwest crow
yeah that does sound like a can you do a
seagull
he's a sexual single oh yeah they do
sound like i'm
kind of like that but they go there
that's a great dog yeah that's a
japanese foreign say something i'm just
gonna hold the kelp
exactly fighting nemo
mine mine oh my my mine yeah
no i don't remember i have no
recollection it surprises me that you
know kids movies
why because i like kid stuff do you
i like cartoons i mean i like i like
animations i think most people like
animations
it doesn't surprise me because he's
exactly like my dad exactly
like your dad's into animations too yeah
he sounds like a cool guy
yeah i'll come home or i'll go visit and
he's like crying to cinderella or
something
what part monsters inc is his favorite
oh that's a good one
sometimes i feel like he's laughing to
annoy the entire room
you know what i mean my dad yeah your
old man yeah cause like he'll be
laughing at some shitty joke in a pixar
movie
and we're all just it's like a chuckle
laugh but he's like [ __ ] slapping him
can you picture joe doing that
of course he doesn't say he doesn't know
what he's laughing at like maybe he's
thinking about like it reminded him of
this kid from his childhood or some [ __ ]
joe's thinking about how sometimes in
space astronauts are upside down and
they don't even know it
that's like my dad that's amazing you
have a cool pops
that's true what is upside down in space
there is there is no upside down
oh you just [ __ ] up the whole room
good for you man hey dude that's i
wonder where your center of gravity is
no dude i've been doing this space app
every [ __ ] day
i love it you're so geeky i love it
[Music]
so there's this thing called skyview or
whatever and it's like free you can just
see where all the planets are
including where the moon is and
everything so you go like this and you
go oh my god i'm under jupiter right now
you're like that right there is
jupiter yeah because we were we were
hanging and i saw [ __ ] jupiter
and you could see it on the phone and i
don't know i thought it was really cool
i had never seen i thought it was just a
random bright star exactly
what happens it sounds pretty cool it's
sky sky view light dude
would love it one of my favorite things
to do hi is watch
things like nature and space and things
on slow-mo
slow mo everything just feels slow
already
i think things go fast in my mind so
things feel slow
okay yep like something's going so fast
that it's
it's actually it's normal time but it
feels slow yeah because your mind when
you're high
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah do you go number five do you
guys ever listen to like podcasts on
like 1.5 speed or any of that yep yeah
all the time because i'm like you talk
too slow man i don't like this to mickey
mouse i don't like it either
i just want to get through it though i'm
like come on but i can't hear the
emotion and the context
to hear the emotion i like that it's
like like if it's an emotional thing
then i do want to hear it that way but
if it's more informative i'm like just
listen
because you can hear the intention of
the person through the tones i'm trying
to get knowledge then i'd rather get it
fast but if i just want to hear the
conversation yeah
then i want it regular time you know
what this reminds me of though
is i like to just search on redfin or
zillow all the time
and go to like these multi-million
dollar mansions and like like i find the
most expensive ones there's
the most expensive one recently was 160
million dollars
and i just i just looked through all the
pictures sometimes i do virtual tours
and i just like pretend i live there i'm
like dude and 50 million of that is just
way fair cabinets yup and it's back
uh what what makes it a hundred like
what stood out to you that was 100
million i don't know
what's so crazy about it is i i honestly
can't see
what they're valuing these things on
because i'll see one for 160 million
it looks just like the one that was 30
million okay i'm like what
negated this like 90 million in the
middle of it like what makes this one 90
million more
they have the same amount of bedroom
same maybe it's the 50 000
cabinets you know what i'm saying could
be the school district yeah
the location is huge well no than the
same location 90 million different close
to a beach
so the 160 million one was in the
mountains i mean like in the
hills like when you're going yeah like
when you're going through sherman oaks
oh it's here yeah yeah i look uh i look
here
some of them are in gated communities
immediately there's a premium too
i think this one was just on top of hill
and it was like all this italian
architecture and it was like an italian
villa it literally looked like a small
town
like they had all these different villas
it's like beauty and the beast and [ __ ]
yeah it was
it was exactly like that sounds like
fountains
helicopter landing pad uh i didn't see
that but
oh is it that one with the garden like
it's got its full
i think i've seen the one because i like
to do the same thing but i didn't even
like that one the best because the ones
i like the best are the ones with the
ocean views and this one did not have an
ocean view it was just like
really secluded in like a mountain it's
so expensive huh
yeah the malibu ones though are actually
cheaper than those ones on the hill
in sherman oaks you know why because
when it rains they
fall true dude no [ __ ] though
mudslides are no joke in california when
it rains
they've all of those cliffside homes
they break in half and then they fall on
the ground i love that we know that and
people are still like i want that one
what if you buy one that already fell
already
fell once so that's kind of like stuck
there right yeah it's got to be stable
now
like yeah okay yeah it seems good
well then the next time it just falls on
you oh [ __ ] that's not good
there is a whole place on the way to
santa barbara yeah la conchita la
conchita
they have mudslides all the time la
conchita
yeah i've never heard of that city
i heard a la canada la crescenta
there's a lock on cheetah it's not
really a city it's like it's like it's
like this one spot
but but they're they're right next to a
mountain and so there's been a bunch of
mudslides there and people have died
even there but people still [ __ ] live
there because it's cheap and you live
across the street from the ocean
[Music]
cheaper
[Music]
i